welcome back to new rockstars this is a
breakdown of the boys season 2 episode 4
nothing like it in the world i'm eric
voss this is the boys underground the
boys after show that
does not kink shame even if your fantasy
is having
sex with your doppelganger that's okay
by us
right marina welcome to the show hi
the the boys underground hosted by 50
women now it is because tommy is off
this week
he won't be gone forever he'll be back
he's he's too funny and too lovable to
uh stay away for too long
also he has keys to all of our
apartments so i was gonna say
[Laughter]
we actually cannot stop him
yeah and uh no judge will sign a
restraining order it's some weird
backwoods western new york
um weird law that we keep yeah yeah
breakthrough
well um i very much enjoyed this episode
it was a nice like um road trip away
from all the drama
and we got to know everyone everyone's
bumping and grinding
and loving and breaking up it was it was
a fun one um
marina why don't you break down the
episode summary for us this episode yes
i will okay so spoiler warning everybody
um as always we are going to talk about
what happened in the episode so if you
haven't watched it
you can't get mad at us but you can get
mad at tommy
yes um so everyone's falling in love
and getting stung hard by it so huey
starlight and
road trip to north carolina and they
learned that liberty
the world war ii hero mallory was asking
about in episode three
is actually storm front so she has a
long it's i know big
big news and eric actually you were
right you were saying
yeah i don't want to take too much
credit because the other 80
of the time i'm not right
actually as i was watching i almost
texted you to be like you were
you [ __ ] you knew about this yeah
yeah i was not gonna praise you i was
going to yell you
she turns out to be the world war ii
hero that mallory was asking about
and uh she has a long history of hate
crimes covered up by
vaught okay so that's a huge deal
um frenchie tries to kiss kimiko and it
does not go well
which um as i saw that i was like good
like that is the reaction
that you should get that is the moment
he read the room
so poorly
okay so it doesn't go well he co he
holds back kimiko from trying to get
revenge on stormfront
um at a rally and butcher sneaks into
the compound
uh where becca is being held and they
hook up
she knows going in that as much as billy
says that he's
fine with the kid and he wants to raise
him and all this stuff she knows that
really deep down he doesn't want to and
it comes out when he like says a
superhero slur
against the kid and it's like wow that
really didn't take much there you go
true colors really didn't take much um
so they part ways homelander hooks up
with doppelganger um
who poses still well uh which is so
weird and then he kills doppelganger
when he looks like himself which is like
very weird um a train gets fired from
the seven
and is replaced by shockwave who
i thought was very funny when he was
like that's right like
he's like peace peace bro um and the
deep is set up
in a sham marriage uh by the
church of the collective which is a
reference to
the church of scientology with tom
cruise and katie holmes
we don't know but like we don't know but
we know we don't know what we know
we don't know you know just take it from
taking from us we live in hollywood
we know we've drive down franklin and we
hear the screams from inside that castle
uh it is a castle this was i'll say
there were parts of this episode that
really
slowed down for me but i think it was
fine i i
i liked that we were coupling off in
this episode
and uh this whole reveal of these
interviews being from
the church of the collective in deep was
such a cool thing yeah
because i kept wondering like who are
these people i thought maybe they would
be interviewing for uh starlight's
new show oh you know uh agents of
starlight or whatever but
yeah yeah but i know this is a much
cooler twist
yeah it was a slower episode but any
episode where like everyone's
is like cool yeah yeah and it had its
its share of dark
moments so yeah the murders are coming
the murders are coming
um all right well i'm gonna break down
ten major easter eggs slash visual
details that you might have missed this
episode because there's some really cool
stuff
that you're watching closely you might
have picked up on so you know as i
predicted last week
many of you said i was nuts or that i
was reaching and every time i see that
i'm always like
okay you might be right i might be
stretching a bit on this one
but if i'm right oh i i will say nothing
to you i will say nothing
i'm not gonna go back and find that
comment again i don't care uh
so yeah we find out that stormfront is
revealed to be liberty the world war ii
era soup and honestly marina i felt this
could have been underlined
way more that's a huge reveal
they just kind of like they were talking
about like oh maybe she just never ages
but we did pick up on some clues leading
this last week we talked about how our
racial slurs
seem a bit antiquated in their phrasing
um
also if you're watching that scene um uh
like in that 70s flashback
they used ayakash's voice as liberty
when she killed that black guy
and it was in a sudden rain storm so i
think that that had
been connected there also some people
picked out how a couple episodes back
she referenced
pippy longstockings as a yeah as
something to call starlight
um i knew what that was because i feel
like my teacher read that to me in first
or second grade
but that is a character that was
definitely more popular
in like the late 40s which would have
been liberty's era
but here was the new visual clue that i
don't think anyone else has spotted
um stormfront's metal armbands she
doesn't always have them on
but uh when she does wear them they have
these american flag imprints
you know it's just like more usa
iconography like homelanders cape
which you know coming from a military
family and kind of like don't wear the
american flag as an article of clothing
okay
it's it's a cape you're going to get
that dirty that's not what the american
flag is for
if if it'd be one thing if it was just
like an american flag print
you know if it was in the color scheme
but it's just
a usa flag that he's wearing as a cape
which feels
disrespectful i think um stains are
gonna get hard be hard to get out
very hard to get out uh those colors
don't run unless you spill
tacos on it good luck but she has these
um these imprints of the flag on her
armbands and uh the american flag when
it's worn on us
military uniforms the stars and the blue
part of the flag are always facing
forward
even though it looks backward on the
right side but the idea is that the flag
is
always charging leading the way into
battle it's never
retreating stormfront's flag armbands
follow this principle but
only when she's in front of cameras in
private
moments like when she got real with
homelander and vaught tower
those armbands were totally reversed the
flags were
retreating huh i think this could be a
subtle way of showing her actual
nazi origins yeah that's a world war ii
experiment by frederick vaught
secretly working in this conspiracy to
undermine america's interests
and force america into a retreating
position that the nazis always dreamed
of we thought we uprooted those nazis
they're still here and you had to root
them out we do not tolerate that
eric but we have to say this because you
know people watch
do rock stars and like oh he looks like
me so he must think the way i think
no not always that's right mother if you
think that eric is on your side
he ain't he ain't whatever you think i'm
the opposite
um there was also a quick shot this
episode i thought was very
interesting that i think was just kind
of like the legend to the map telling us
to pay attention to flags this episode
there was a mural of homelander when
they were going to the south
and his american flag cape was rendered
into a confederate flag
yeah yeah yeah and i'll say while i take
issue with you wearing the american flag
as an article of clothing
if you want to you know disrespect the
confederate flag go right ahead
stay away yeah yeah yeah moving on uh
second detail we get another billy joel
references episode i love how every
episode this season we are kidding
the billy joel song yeah uh always a
reference to
huey and robin's final exchange in the
pilot and that's become a big thing now
with huey
and starlight they sing we didn't start
the fire and that look on his face when
she knew the words he's like
i found her it was so sweet um but a lot
of people are pointing out
that song was from billy joel's album
called
stormfront
third detail in the first three episodes
fresco was kind of the random product
placement right
well this episode it was almond joys
they are so happy they all enjoy so
happy
to finally get uh some shout outs like
it's our time
um well we saw it twice actually annika
the vaught analyst is eating one black
noir makes her throw it away
later starlight eats an almond joy the
vending machine and huey thinks it's
gross
the reason i bring this up is because
comic readers have been you know biting
our tongues about black noise
comic twist i'm not gonna bring up here
but
i wonder instead and i'm only speaking
in code to the people who read the
comics
there might be some connection between
black noir and huey
based on their mutual disgust with
almond joy
candy bars so just think about that this
might become important later i don't
know i haven't seen the future episode
so this is perfect because
eric knows what happens in the comics
and i don't so you do get that like
balance of like what i think is just
like huh what does that mean and then
eric's like
actually knows everything means
everything
all right fourth detail there are a
bunch of signs at stormfronts rally one
reads
the number seven in uh superman shield
outline
just a fun dc reference there now fifth
detail one of my favorite moments was
homelander just scrolling through all of
stormfront's memes
so funny and because this is what we do
here at new rockstars we've got to go
through these frame by frame just
because it was hard to catch all of them
but all of them are amazing so i'm just
gonna run through them quickly
there was she has no sympathy for
[ __ ]
tries to save the city couldn't even
save his reputation
saving america hello [ __ ] that was
homelanders coming face it looks like
is milk face there was one with black
noir with a teacup
did you hear about storm front the t is
skaldensis
laughing at homelander me receiving the
glory of stormfront's posts
the classic unfaithful boyfriend meme
was funny
everyone turned around from my homeland
or two stormfront i love that one
searching for a single forgive about
homelander
uh there was the girls get a done bot
poster we've seen there's a mushroom
cloud with
homelander's mind when he found out
about a woman is stronger than him
go home homie you are drunk and then the
segway scooter ones with me and the
squad on our way to
respect stormfront and then bye
homelander
and then this really quick one someone
please touch my tiny dick sad face
which someone does offer to touch his
tiny dick later but he turns yeah
uh stormfront smiling in front of a
house fire with homelanders career
caught one for your homelander and it's
a fish with super terrorist
homelander waving from a trash bin uh
and then a feeding a pill to a cat
internet store for content me uh haitian
homelander burns 400 calories per hour
storm front on jesus's body it looks
like she did that when will homelander
actually save us
and then home later with a clown wig and
nose and then stormfront with
test me [ __ ] in comic sans i know the
way that i
look at my memes is on a television with
a clicker
what was that someone must have had to
set up like a keynote for him and he's
just like
and that poor tech was like i'm not
gonna include the really mean ones
yeah but i have to include some of the
mean ones so he knows i'm not lying
so because they'll know he'll confront
me in an elevator and
try to crack a rib bone now what's
interesting is stormfront totally admits
this episode that all these memes are
being generated by just like five dudes
that she pays in arby's gift cards which
marina by the way i will accept that
payment
if anybody wants to pay me and arby's
gift cards
he loves please i want my big beef and
jenner
and um and yeah last week we did talk
about how stormfront's internet
following might all be [ __ ] and
she's just freely admitted now that it's
manufactured being amplified
by the echo chamber of social media just
an interesting statement on all these
kind of grassroots internet campaigns
really it's probably a small group of
people just really committed
and knowing where to post and when to
post all these things all right six
detail a train gets fired from the seven
uh that was hinted by the newspaper in
episode one he's replaced with shockwave
um he offers to help with a fitness
initiative he loves fat kids but there
was a detail here
the statue in the bot office in the
background between homelander
and a train was a figure with a missing
leg
who's having trouble running just like a
train is having trouble
moving quickly because of his issues
seventh detail homeland of course hangs
out with stillwell but yes actually just
doppelganger whom
stillwell if you remember did previously
used to blackmail the senator in season
one
the framing in these shots was really
creepy
it points the camera right down you mean
the titties yeah
it's it doesn't leave anything really
the imagination it really i think the
idea of it
she looks good you know uh i just think
you can't say that i can't say that i
could say she looks good with the
shrug i think i can see that much maybe
yeah
now i think the whole idea of this was
for it to feel very um
you know pervy and uh voyeuristic like
we're seeing an angle that we shouldn't
be seeing
and i think it's just to make us feel
unsettled by this kind of like
infantile nuzzling that he does um also
marina if you think about it homelander
had to set this up with doppelganger
walk him through the
milk finger sucking routine like what
was that conversation like
he handed him a script and was like this
is how i get
my num nums stick your fingers in this
glass of milk
and then feed it to me he's like you
don't want to just drink the milk no it
needs to be suckled from your face yeah
and then he was like he was like you
want me to do this
and he was like yes and he was like
isn't that a little weird and he was
like no
nothing's weird you're weird shut up
yeah go to your room
because like doppelganger i mean was he
consenting to i
assumed doppelganger was being forced to
do that if not
outright then he just made his glo
homelander made his glowy eyes
you know oh yeah and he was like okay
i'll do it you know
he was holding him as yeah yeah i think
that's what was scariest about this show
now at any moment when homeland is not
on screen i assume he could burst
through the wall and snap someone's neck
or just laser someone to death yeah yeah
he's so frightening he's kind of this
like looming presence over everyone
um now in this weird cabin in the woods
they're watching scorsese's taxi driver
uh specifically the moment travis bickle
blows off the guy's fingers which in
that movie
it's really one of the most
homelander-esque violent moments
homelander definitely relates to travis
bickle as a dude who feels threatened
that his masculinity is being stripped
away from him
and whenever that happens he responds by
going berserk for no reason he's not an
actual hero
and in the same way that like the boys
subverts your expectations of the
superman trope as someone you expect to
be a hero but he's actually a rotten
person
that's what taxi driver is all about
you're not meant to relate with travis
bickle
he's a flawed broken human being who
sees himself as the hero of his own
story
but actually he's a he's a sociopath
who has no emotional connection to
anyone
and is just looking for an excuse to
blow people away yeah
okay now for me one of the worst things
i think we've seen homelander do on this
series and it's like they're trying to
find more creative ways for him
for us to hate him even more yeah
forcibly
outs maeve on live tv yeah this guy
yeah was so rotten um
and the reason he does it is to like
serve himself to like try to say the
seven have representation
despite this hero's so white campaign
this is just me
he also does the thing that everybody
[ __ ] does
where someone points out a lack of
diversity
and like for example this is heroes so
white right and they go
oh but we have a gay white lady and
it's like you cannot substitute
right one like underrepresented
demographic
for another like she's still
white like just because she's a lesbian
or
is bi whatever whatever she identifies
as that character
like people are like oh it's fine
because like one of them's a lesbian and
it's like
[ __ ] there's still no the one black guy
is now gone like
she didn't she's not and that was yeah
this was after he fired uh a train right
so
he's like he's lying about that too
that's the real point is like
yeah he's getting defensive and when
people bring up these things it's not
so that you can have a response and say
like well actually we have these tokens
that
right no it's that's not what it's about
the point is to just like
take in the criticism look at your own
system the way you're bringing people in
and try to change and
try to change rather than get defensive
about it i thought it was written
very well because that is exactly what
everybody does
like we have a gay white woman though
and it's like and i was like yeah that's
what people do
like yeah they did they did it you are
right that
the the way the homophobia was written
in this episode was
super accurate uh and not like over the
top like you know
in like early 2000s movies where they're
like this is why you're gross to be gay
it's kind of like the weird passive
aggression
and if you think about the whole thing
with the heroes so white campaign
it came about because this whole reveal
that supes are being made not born
scientists realized that bot chose this
to make soups
92 white it wasn't just a happy accident
it was a choice
um but uh but yeah with homelanders
homophobia there's like a really
interesting moment i don't know if you
caught it too marina where like
he's totally down to sleep with himself
too
yeah to himself uh
he's he's ready to do it but then
there's a little moment where
doppelganger says
it's not even gay if it's with yourself
right and then you can see the shift in
homelander's face it's the word gay
triggered his homophobia in that moment
and in that moment he decides that he
has to kill doppelganger because
doppelganger has
he realizes oh he saw that i was down to
do this he saw that i'm vulnerable and
broken
i have to kill him now and yeah i have
to kill someone who looks like me
because i hate myself
yeah yeah it's such a well-acted moment
by i know i hate that character but it
was so
well acted yeah like i was like like
every time i watch a show i'm like oh i
hate him
that actor though yeah really he's great
he plays it perfectly
so good something i want to note here
marina doppelganger doesn't revert back
to his normal self when his neck is
snapped he stays as
dead homelander which is crazy right
yeah it really underlines the thing he
has to look down his own dead body
mm-hmm it was very very horrible uh now
the last thing i will point out is
uh the whole framing device this episode
we were talking about this the wife
interviews uh from the deep
the women we met olive cassandra gianna
all for the church of the collective to
arrange this weird marriage
rehabilitated his image
we talked about scientology and its
connections there uh but it also seems
to be setting up another threat to vote
like we have the boys we have the media
and the heroes so white campaign we have
the inner coup
from edgar and stormfront and now we got
this weird religious cult coming in
but cassandra that was you know the
candidate that was chosen for
deep brings up the lovers of valdaro
which are six thousand year old
skeletons found embracing each other
discovered in italy in 2007
she may not realize the fact that in
recent chromosomal studies
both skeletons were revealed to be male
cute isn't that interesting now we don't
know if it was a lover's embrace
they could have just died and held each
other and who knows how they
identified but like this whole
assumption that there was a male and a
woman
it's like no they were dudes and this is
something that is normal and has been
around since yeah
mankind has been around um so i think
it's interesting when you put it in the
context of the whole episode
this whole episode you know it's called
nothing else like it in the world
everyone's horny is you got booker and
betcha
betcha you betcha you got booker betcha
uh there's homelander and himself slash
homelander and stillwell frenchies
trying to make the move on kimiko
deep has all his wife interviews they're
all showing these different types of
relationships
but they're all kind of [ __ ] up and
they all don't work out the only two
people who are left
embracing are these ancient skeletons
that in a weird way is the truest love
that we see
in this episode and how there's nothing
else like it in the world now because
those two are gone
and we're left with these complicated
broken people who cannot connect with
each other
eric that's so sad
that's why at the end that reveal i was
like oh what a cool the whole episode i
was like how is this all connecting
yeah and then remembering back and and
discovering that thing about the lovers
of eldar i'm like i get it
like what a it was such an interesting
through line i think
it's so depressing it's sad
um but on that note um i've learned
something
even more important that i have to tell
you about but i gotta switch things
around here
look i know there's a lot of clues we
gotta sift through because the best
visual clues are hiding in plain sight
just like someone's front pocket wallet
like the ridge
thanks to the ridge for sponsoring this
episode the ridge helps you carry what
you need every day
from their flagship ridge wallet to
their portable charging commuter
backpack they want you to make the most
out of what you're bringing with you the
ridge wallet is made out of
military-grade materials like titanium
and carbon fiber it has a clean
stylish design it is
so when jason voorhees is trying to kill
you he won't be able to kill your credit
cards
this is their aluminum silver wallet
they do have other colors including some
very flashy tiki designs
this thing is light it's strong just
like you
they make it easy to buy with free
shipping and free returns and a lifetime
guarantee it's also got thirty thousand
five star reviews so you know they're
doing something right they also have
great backpacks and travel bags with
rfid blocking pockets and the optional
device charging batteries get 10
off today with free worldwide shipping
and returns by going to ridge.com
newrockstars that's ridge.com new
rockstars and use the code
new rockstars find the link in the
video's description all right
let's let's talk about some discussion
questions we have from this episode
shall we yes yes all right so uh marina
let's start with talking about this
whole
backstory with stormfront and liberty um
you know
apparently stormfront never ages neither
do her racist views
what do you think this tells us about
bots history
why do you think stan edgar brought her
back into the seven what's his what's
his plan
right um okay so last episode
when homelander learned the history
of vaught as a company as stan edgar was
talking um and homelanders kind of like
not paying attention
like blah blah blah uh i didn't say this
when we did our episode um of the boys
underground at the time but while i was
watching that
in my head i was like oh vat
is that same
thing like it's the same formula it's
the same people
it's the same everything like they're
gonna
like the history is like oh yeah they
distance themselves like
they start it over it's a different this
it's a different that it's not it's the
same
in my head i was like oh it's the same
thing all of it is the same in fact
it's the same hero so i think she's one
of the original
people who got the serum maybe even the
first one yeah
so she's the original everything
and she can't age which is a super power
we would all love to have um
and i think maybe like her blood is the
key to something so she
can't like stan edgar can't get rid of
her
and he knows that because she doesn't
age and no one can kill her
so he kind of doesn't have a choice and
also last week
i was like it's smart to bring her back
in because homelander is
issuing his authority sort of like
putting his foot down he's kind of like
testing the waters for how much you can
get away with or whatever
and it's so smart of stan edgar to
bring in somebody or bring back somebody
who
is apparently one of the only people on
the planet who can
physically keep homelander in check yeah
like he she's one of the only people who
could potentially kill him
if need be and if i were him i would tot
totally bring her back just to have a
check on homelanders power
if nothing else yeah she kind of seems
like the um
the old guard you know like uh when when
your new rookies are out of control you
bring back
in the old uh the old dude who you kind
of trust
and you know before mallory stillwell
was keeping homelander in check without
mallory still well i think stan edgar's
like all right we might have to take
care of this guy so i'm gonna bring back
in this sneaky ageless
soup just to keep an eye on him and keep
him in check yeah that seems yeah good
strategy
um okay so eric um let's check in with
our weekly
noir watch uh all right so i watched so
in this episode black noir
pressures the analyst to track billy
butcher was
really funny butcher i know
i know he didn't even have to write it
like that he wrote it with a crayon
yeah just scribbled it but maybe he just
wanted some nice meat cuts
yes he's waiting so yeah he's like why
is she showing me this one guy
yeah yeah i don't know where the butcher
is um but the question is so why is he
so interested in him ah that's a very
good question i think that's something
that it's gonna be a guiding thing
the whole mystery with black noir
because yeah we we're keeping an
eye on this guy he was crying when he
found out that superheroes are
are made not born last season we saw him
playing piano expertly
uh he started this season killing off
the soup terrorist
oh yep i don't i think
he might have been involved with uh
getting that baby
out of the house in that moment i think
he might have been there
uh and i think he sees something in
butcher
uh as a way to maybe help him uh maybe
he has some kind of connection to uh
i i if if he cared more about um becca
then he would have known
it wasn't until they had gone through
the security tapes for hours and hours
that that's where they finally found
billy butcher so i don't think um
black nor has so much of a connection to
becca i think once he saw that billy
butcher has an axe to grind with
homelander
black horse sees some kind of connection
there i don't think his uh
his goals are antagonistic with billy
butcher i'll say that
you you know what that's cool because
the whole time i was watching too i was
like why is he care i mean i know why he
cares but like
i was like why yeah um and but also
he can't really explain so he can't use
his words yet block jar
that makes sense to me um and since
you're doing so well
let's see what you have to say about
this so um why
was mm's father fighting vaught in court
right first of all yep
how did he die um and
do we think mm's ocd is connected to
the death or any of that that's a good
thought yeah because they both kind of
came up the same episode right
i you know i i don't know um like he
they said that he was fighting them in
court even the actor in the
in like on the amazon aftershow saying
that he had to ask some follow-up
questions to the writers about uh
because he had asked was the death
murder was it like an assassination
uh and he believes that he died of
natural causes
but stress that was brought on by
fighting vot
in court yeah i'm thinking maybe it had
to do something with mm
maybe um maybe he was trying to protect
mm and he was fighting i mean look
everyone has a reason to sue vaught
you know that's one thing we're learning
they over everyone in every possible way
but i think you are absolutely right
that mm's ocd is directly related to it
i mean he talked about hearing his dad
uh typing on the typewriter
and then he taps his finger every time
he changes the lane
so i think like his and i wonder if his
dad died of something that had to do
with some kind of like illness
and that's why he wanted to like keep
his hands clean and everything wanted to
be clean
maybe the kid had to like clean up his
dad's like maybe his dad you know offed
himself and the kid had to like clean it
up and then that blood is always on his
hands so that's why he's like always
going to wash his hands
and i think no it makes sense and
actually
if i'm not mistaken um ocd is
if not caught it's not caused but it is
worsened by a traumatic
event traumatic life events so like like
a death of a loved one it can make
symptoms
way way worse even if they're really
mild before um
so that makes total sense and it sounds
like he might have inherited
you know his dad seems like a compulsive
person the fact that he kept going off
after vaught working all night like this
might have been something like in his
family and then you're right at
that moment worsened it all right marina
i wanna know from you
now that a train's fired from the seven
what do you think his next move is gonna
be
um okay so uh
so he he he has to stop running right
and he's also addicted to compound v
so he know the the only thing he really
wants
is to keep himself stable right like he
had that exchange with starlight where
he was like you know the only people who
saved monies and everything is
rich people and i was like um
so he in my head
he like goes public with everything
except for killing his girlfriend
but he's like i've been struggling i had
to get sober i went through re
yeah why not i'm the people's hero and
then he basically
becomes the rock and like starts acting
and starts like becomes like the biggest
like athletic figure
turned entertainer turned actor turned
like worldwide global force and why not
that's where the money is
yeah he's like the richest person in the
world and he's just like [ __ ]
[ __ ] up get your money oh man yeah he's
uh he's perfectly set up for that
or you know like i don't know if he's
that crazy about the boys because he has
that tension with huey obviously
but like if they can start picking off
some of the uh members of the seven to
join them they already kind of have
starlight
like oh yeah could a train join up i
guess i don't know
we'll see your theory is based on like
real things in my theory is based on
like what i
just want to happen well i think yours
actually is more realistic to the real
world than a train
you know deciding that he can make peace
with huey
because he hates shockwave that much
yeah don't feel shame marina you
what you pitched was was good one of us
has read knows what happens in the
comics and one of us
but they diverge so much from the comics
this is like more than
any other show or movie we've talked
about the boys
has diverged more from its source
material so you're saying
there's a chance
and i think the last thing we should
talk about is uh what's next for
billy butcher because i'll tell you at
the start of the season i was like oh he
just wants to get becca back and then
it seems like they put a pause on that
now after this episode
i know um i this is not what's gonna
happen
but when he when she left him or
whatever
i was like go to therapy that's all you
need just go to there
everyone just should just please go to
therapy just talk about
your problems please he's been ignoring
like working on himself and
she straight up told him like [ __ ]
you've always you've always been
like [ __ ] up and now you gotta work on
yourself and i was like
maybe you'll finally go to therapy maybe
that hey that'd be good um now before
marina breaks down the kill counts in
this episode we uh do want to do a bit
of follow-up on this whole exploding
head mystery
we're gonna go back through the trailer
there is totally a soup that looks like
they're going to be breaking out of the
facility
who has the ability to explode heads i
think the concern is that vaught might
be using people like that
to do their assassinations for them uh
or obviously stormfront
uh might be using that on behalf of stan
edgar as opposed to everyone on the
seven or
bot um so it looks like it's it's not
the fly crawling into the ear
tommy it looks like there's just a soup
who does that who turns people into soup
so who uh won the kill counts this week
great so this was a low murder um
episode
um so homelander had one kill um which
was doppelganger
uh the shapeshifter of course um which
what a way to go
i mean come on you offer to suck a guy's
dick and then he kills you like come on
come
on he was doing something nice but you
know
in a way and you already talked about
this eric like yeah he kills
doppelganger but
metaphorically speaking he really like
killed himself and you could think about
it of
he killed his former self and his former
self is the one that
gave a [ __ ] about what other people
thought that's right
it was kind of the the only thing
holding him back from becoming a true
monster
i mean publicly so now that's dead and
when i saw that i was like oh [ __ ] like
now he's gonna basically
just go free like balls to the wall bad
um bad buh
uh and stormfront also has one kill so
uh and but it's a flashback right so we
see her as liberty
um she killed myron who is um the
brother of the woman that they go to
interview
uh the motorist in the 70s um and we
also have an adjustment from last week
so
guess that's right so we had guessed
that stormfront had killed around a
dozen people when she went
just tearing through that yeah she
killed a lot more staring
tearing through that building uh it was
a little bit better just like yeah
but it turns out it was 59
people oh my god and something we should
also point out
like we didn't really stress this last
episode but
those were targeted kills everyone who
died there seemed to be a person of
color
she was aiming for black people it was
really messed up yeah yeah it was
totally
um and kimiko's brother right so if you
add all that together
she's killed 60 people yo yup at least
there's
gonna be even more bodies i'm sure that
she stacks up
and absolutely i'll be interested to see
i don't think any of those bodies are
gonna be white
unless you know she kills one of the
people we know
she's gonna be very selective about who
she kills yeah yeah
the um the the death of the show the
kill of the show
uh for this episode was not any of the
physical murders
it was the death of my relationship with
milk
[Laughter]
you still had it starting this episode i
was like
they're gonna let it go i know
eric's vegan now yep hey and you know we
should also give an honorable mention to
the north carolina semi truck that looks
like he might have killed two people but
we don't know
who we are i know i almost wrote that
down but yeah yeah wasn't confirmed
i was grossed out by the milk yep uh
well that is our show this week it was
so great to chat with you marina thanks
for breaking down this numbers for us so
it's always fun to chat with you uh for
everyone watching or listening tune in
every week for our reactions to the
latest boys episode the following day
uh here on youtube or here on your
podcast network wherever you get your
podcasts
you'll get the show actually earlier in
the video version if you listen to the
podcast version it's a big help to us
here on new rockstars
if you are a big podcaster please if you
could give us a great rating and review
that really helps us if we could trend
that would be awesome uh it's just one
of these weird things that gets us on
the map
uh and helps us do morning dreams about
it yeah tommy does
yeah he tells us all his dreams and we
wish he wouldn't we don't know how to
leave that slack channel
and as i said judges will not sign the
restraining order
a reminder you can join our official
discord by becoming a patron at
patreon.comrockstars and on discord
we'll be trying to field some questions
that we'll answer on the show
so you definitely want to be there if
you want to be part of the conversation
you can follow me at eavos follow
marina marina mastros and follow new
rockstars and all of our socials
subscribe here on youtube or wherever
you're listening so you get too much
information on
all the stuff you care about uh see you
next week marina
bye no more milk bye home later
[Music]
you